how awesome is it to be here with artem  is this your guys's red carpet debut oh  you're making me a little hot now um  yeah is that what it's called  okay there was Abe you are you gonna  slate it thank you thank you you know  he's got some good on candy and likewise  I think Vice likewise  something tells me date nights aren't as  fancy as this no no this is definitely  an exception why was improper you guys  to show up tonight and support bending  in the family um you know I know he  worked with bindi on the show on Dancing  with the Stars and when he mentioned  this I mean I do a lot of animal stuff  myself  and so when he invited me to go was like  absolutely I love supporting this you  know cause animals and I love that he  has a connection to her personally so  are you watching Dancing with the Stars  at all you want to talk I never did I  have recently yes I actually went to the  show last week it was so much fun so  yeah he's not a bad dancer that autumn  pretty good haha